-Finally, guys, we have exactly
nine shows left before we go on
Christmas break, which means
it's time for that
beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Nine days left ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
Every show between now and
Christmas, we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a superb Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas" cabinet.
Since there are nine shows left,
let's open door number nine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You feeling it?
-Yeah.
-Whoo! Alright, let's see it.
Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
The head -- the he-- your head
comes through the chimney?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
This is a special, special
sweater right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. A lot going on.
Now let's see who is going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants this sweater?
It's a one of a kind.
It's a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
2-3-9.
♪♪
Come on down. Come on down.
Hey!
Nice to see ya.
Stand over there.
How are ya?
-Good, how are you?
-I'm great. What's your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Sarah.
I live in New York, actually.
-Yeah, it's a local New Yorker.
That's what I'm talking about.
Sarah, do you have anything like
this in your wardrobe?
-I don't.
But I'm totally wearing it.
I'm totally gonna wear it.
-Yeah.
Would you like
to wear it tonight?
-Yeah.
Oh, you want me to put it on?
I'll put it on right now.
-Yeah. I'd love it. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Be careful with it.
-How do I --
-I don't -- I don't know how.
But your head somehow comes
through the chimney hole.
I think you're right.
Can you feel my hand?
-Yes.
-Okay. Where --
No, not your hands, your head.
-No, yes.
-Yeah, your hands go
through the sleeves.
-We got it.
-Oh, oh, wait, this is --
Yeah, perfect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God. It's perfect.
Yes, it looks great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
That's fantastic.
Look at how good you look.
It looks so --
Come on, give her a round of --
Sarah from New York.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Happy holidays.
Thank you.
-Stick around. We'll be right
back with "WeTweet," everybody.
Come on back to the show.
♪♪